good morning I'm Marianne Kelso from
Olympic College in Bremerton Washington
and I'm work a full-time math professor
Olympic College and I'm working on a
project with computational class notes
to put college algebra online using a
hybrid course model and we're using
Mathematica wolfram mathematica to
program the book I wrote so it's an
e-book and it'll all be available on the
Internet
okay good afternoon my name is Marianne
Kelso I'm a full-time math faculty
Olympic College in Bremerton Washington
which is west of Seattle and yes there
is something west of Seattle several
people have said no there's nothing west
of Seattle Seattle's on the coast well
Seattle isn't on the coast it's on the
puget sound so so this is a picture of
one of the buildings and the plaza out
in front which is I think really quite
remarkable and I'm partnering with
computational class notes to do this
project I'm working on so both logos
will be scattered throughout the
presentation you might ask how did I get
started with computational or why do I
pair I won't tell you how I got started
with them but why am I paired with
computational class notes and I haven't
programmed since the early 90s and in
the early 90s I programmed with fortran
77 so I do understand programming but
it's been a long time so I wrote a
college algebra textbook and they're the
ones that are programming it for me so
see if I got everything I i I've like
Mary Ann here in the front row both of
us did our first lines of Mathematica
code tuesday at the class that they
taught before we started the conference
okay so cloud powers has shortened the
name of the topic to cloud powered
mathematics a computational foundation
for student success ok Albert Einstein
said education is not the learning of
facts but the training of the mind often
our education is the learning of facts
rather than training our minds how to
think we with at Olympic College and
computational class notes are interested
in the training of the mind
okay so we have some common goals we
want to make sure students learn math
but we want to have them remember what
they learned okay and we don't think
students should have to pay publishers
shareholder dividends so we're trying to
put publishers out of business and we
know that the more active practice
students have the more they learn it's a
little like trying to learn how to swim
you can't learn how to swim unless you
put your face in the water and actually
move your arms and legs so with math
it's kind of the same thing we want them
to experiment we want them to do some
computation perhaps with pencil and
paper and sometimes just in your head we
want them to learn how to graph and then
there will be exercises which include
homework and in any community college
you got to have assessment so wolfram
mathematica helps bring concepts alive
for visualization and students are going
to use ordinary technology devices
instead of textbooks ordinary tech
devices are usually much much much much
cheaper than even one textbook course
content will be available everywhere
Wi-Fi is so you can do your homework at
home or at the local starbucks or
wherever you are and accessibility will
be is built in as we work through this
and by that I mean the American for
disabilities act in terms of
accessibility okay so a friend of mine
said this I've been told this a lot when
I was working through the education
system that kiddush maths I mean like
children's math requires kiddush text so
you don't have to have high tech things
for the little kids but you know little
kids stuff probably requires the most
advanced text and often more advanced
than
college level mathematics sometimes in
college level mathematics were so
self-motivated in the self discipline
that we can take care of ourselves
whereas K through 12 sometimes needs
more work so CCN and i hope to League
college algebra using the Wolfram plowed
and mathematica with the actual online
books ready by 2017 so what are we going
to do with this program we're going to
reduce cost to students as the cost of
smartphones decreases maybe to less than
twenty dollars they can become almost
disposable if it breaks then you can buy
another one and they can become an
educational tool for use in these
modules as you're going through a lesson
you get a whole screen of exercises or
examples I mean and if you refresh you
get a whole screen of different examples
so there's almost unlimited supply of
examples for students instead of the
static four to six that are giving in a
hard covered book hardbound book and
this is going to eliminate the need for
updates which means no public you know
the publisher after three or four years
says well we have to update besides
we're not getting any income because the
bookstores are getting all the resale
income and we're not selling any new
books so but we don't have that problem
we can update sort of on the fly on on
online so that brings us to a question
can topics and math be approached in a
manner similar to topics and physics and
chemistry sort of an investigative
approach can we do that this means if we
can do this this means that instructors
professors teachers are going to have to
give students back the power over their
own learning I'm going to have to stop
being the state sage on the stage
if you will which is going to challenge
a lot of us because we like that role
and can we use the tremendous power of
modern computers and wolfram mathematica
to provide an abundance of experiments
to students I only hope so so why have
computers if we don't use their
manipulation to manipulate an almost
unending stream of examples and then
they will help the professor define and
generalize a concept we're not going to
give you y equals MX plus B and help
think you should in a rote manner work
with it we want you to see some things
play with some things and then we will
work it out together yeah this is going
to be hard for me too okay so we're
going to look at three topics I don't
think we're probably going to get
through all three but I'm prepared for
three and then we'll see what happens I
am very adamant about keeping to the 30
minutes that were allotted so my
presentation is supposed to last 20 and
then you have questions and then there's
five minutes for moving to the next
place okay why is any math topic and
issue for students well for the moat for
part of it is we've been conditioned
especially we as women oh you don't need
to be good in math you're just going to
you know get married and have babies
that's the story I was told I don't know
if there's still terrible in that story
or not but that's the story I was told
so I didn't have to be good at math I
was but that's not important sometimes
books are a little challenging for our
students they are not able to adapt to
new methods of learning if a school
district adopts a math textbook they
probably keep it for 10 years and that's
a long time especially now is the
technology is changing so quickly so how
do we find a solution
I don't know I'm constrained at my
Community College to teach a certain
library of concepts so I don't have a
lot of freedom to move however i want to
but the solution i'm trying for the
pilot in january will be a hybrid course
and students will not be required to
attend class every day they will have to
come to class the first week and then
any time after that when there's a
scheduled exam or quiz because if johnny
is enrolled in the class I don't want
his uncle John taking the quizzes so
you'll have you know they'll have to
come partly there were there's always a
cohort of students who like to be in
class they like to have the class there
that you know some of us need some
outside discipline imposed upon us and
if I make myself come to class then I'll
probably actually study for that hour
while I should have been you know should
be in class so that's what I'm
developing right now and those for those
who come to class there will be an
opportunity for more individual
instruction or for more questions to be
answered for me rather than if I'm
teaching you know the sage on the stage
thing for maybe 20 or 30 minutes and
then worksheets or homework or what have
you so it's going to be a huge mindset
change for me but I'm thinking I think
I'm getting there ok and you say well
how we're going to do this well at
Olympic College I have a math colleague
who tracks success in all of our math
courses so he can take my students from
these two excuse me I have two sections
of college algebra and he will track
them from when they leave my class
through any other math classes they take
through graduation and if they go to
school in at a state institution in
washington they can be tracked through
there too so
we have a good system to track and see
which programs but it takes a while for
students to work through all those steps
okay so how does this solution help a
student obtain results so let's so we're
to start by modeling linear functions
and it's a pretty simple concept but a
lot of students have trouble with the
slope part and the y-intercept part ok
so at Olympic College in precalc one
college algebra students do review
linear functions and their applications
prior to moving on to polynomials of
higher degree okay so students sometimes
recognize linear functions from the rote
learning in a pre college level class
some have seen the y equals MX plus B
part but some have not seen the function
notation so we're putting both notations
in the the lessons so here we go so
through a dynamic module we're going to
provide students with an almost
unlimited supply of experiments which
will help them visualize what is
happening when dealing with linear
functions so they'll get a visual
understanding and intuitive
understanding we hope they will do some
calculations so visually intuitively and
calculational ly they should get a day
that gives us a whole comprehensive
package for our students visually you
know they have will show you AI have
some modules that do the visual which
will help with more intuitive when
they're looking for to calculate slope
and intercept okay so that's the bulk of
my presentation so now I'm going to look
at
some examples and this first one has to
do with linear functions and this is
where when I was practicing in the ready
room things got a little bit dicey but
we'll see what happens aha ok so here is
a whoops here is a an example and that's
not on my desktop but notice that the
y-intercept stays the same and as the
slope changes the magenta dot stays on
the line in the first window and we can
watch the slope changing from positive
to negative and the numbers getting
closer and closer to 0 and the second
and third in the second window we see
all the points that are less than and
notice that we see the less than in the
Y in that first equality there and then
in the third window again we have the
magenta dot that stays in the greater
than window so they can play with this
and let's see you've got ok I can have a
look over here to see use my mouse is
that the same was the y-intercept six
before I can't remember let's try
another one
we must not be hooked up to the Internet
it looks to me like the same one keeps
coming up it looks like the Wi-Fi is off
on my desktop is that this one I don't
know but I think we'll see as we go if
if it's if there's another problem as we
move through when i get my phone on i
think you'll see I don't know either but
anyway that's the first one of the first
things they see and then we go to this
one whoops okay this is another one only
this time it's a little bit faster we
made it slow the first time so students
will get a better sense of but this was
you know it's going to push them a
little harder and what I like about this
is that all the slopes are not integer
values and all the Y values are not
interested integer values students get
to the point where they think all values
when you're in a math class should be
integers and that's an ugly number you
know 5 240 sevenths is an ugly number
and I just say no no no that's my
favorite number and they look at me and
roll their eyes like my kids used to do
so okay so the y-intercept is at
negative 7 ah it changed this time there
must have been something wrong with the
other link so I'm not going to worry
about it but you get the sense of what's
happening here don't you and there's you
know on and on and on we can make as
many of these as we want
okay and then this one again gives y
equals MX plus B but you're probably
going to i'm probably going to have to
give a short lecture before we get to
this module to tell bit because they
haven't seen the Delta Y over Delta X
notation yet they've seen the y2 minus
y1 over x2 minus x1 in previous classes
so we're going to have to talk about you
know those two values and where they
come when that's and that's you know
where the change in Y over the change in
X comes from and I like the deltas
symbolism because it does start getting
them into thinking about change as a
delta a change in Delta so anyway and
again notice we don't have any we don't
have many integers here with our two Y
values and our two x values so I think
at this point they would probably have
to use their calculator but if you look
at the far right ratio over here if you
think about that in terms of approximate
values you know that 24 divided by
positive 6 is going to give you a
negative 4 so it should help them with
their you know checking to see if their
numbers make sense because students
don't always do that they don't always
check to see if their numbers make sense
okay so in this page we have the same
linear function but we have three
different sets of arbitrary points and
another a different slope value of the
one of negative 6 and is that a plus 8
over there I can't yeah which is a
different y intercept
two points two points two points so okay
so let's close that and then from my
desktop I'm hoping I can do this
is the where is the there it is
okay there we go I want to minimize this
okay now I can bring it back here on my
desktop just in case your mother ever
says that this is too hard for old women
to learn you can always use a different
example I graduated from college in 92
I'm a new now is I'm a late bloomer okay
so here's another kind of thing that we
use notice in this example we have
sliders so they can learn to move the
slider back and forth they all have to
program it they can also recognize you
know that if you click on the plus sign
that you can enter a particular value
and zero is boring so and then use the
slider the way we all do with step
backwards play step forwards faster
forward slower forward and then forward
so we can change the slope we can change
the y-intercept and we can change the
number of dots in the spray with this
particular one goes from 50 up to 400 so
they really get a visual of what's going
on okay so then for what it's worth I
failed physics but here's a physics
application with look at all the sliders
and the graph that they that's been
generated with the position vector the
velocity vector and the acceleration
vector and this as we've seen in other
presentations we can move around we can
change the slider look at time and watch
that time vector go along the curve so
there's a lot of things available for us
here using these ah here's an example of
a quiz and this is from Ryerson
University in Toronto so I'm just going
to pick arbitrarily what's going on here
now i'm going to leave the last one
blank submit it and it doesn't submit
look what it tells you tells you you
forgot one this is a homework exercise
so you know there's no grading okay so
guess what I answered the first one
wrong they give me the my answer the
right answer I can look at the solution
or I can click on the PDF button and get
a solution that's printable if I want to
print it out and look at it that way
also if I'm not sure I need some
additional help I can go here and they
have a variety depending on what topic
you're doing and have a variety of
support services here and you can try
another practice set and do it all over
again so I think that's quite remarkable
and then the last thing I want to do is
show you that it is compatible with your
iPhone maybe now it worked
it worked before in the ready room do
you know why it's not working oh now
it's up that was up there it's just not
here okay so let's go to one of those
ones we looked at before there we go
have to hit it right it looks like
something you've seen before but look
how nicely it comes up on my this is an
iphone it works on androids as well and
this is the same example we saw before
and we can see another example and
another example and another example so
these links i have here are just like
the ones i had in the presentation okay
all right so that's it any questions no
the pricing is instead of buying a
textbook at $150 the students will pay
fifty five dollars and they'll get the
text the modules which they can just use
online or they can print off if they
want to they'll get the homework which
was what we were looking at the a minute
ago and will get the quizzes and tests
for $55 instead of 150 and it's paper
free it's not that heavy textbook that
they have to carry around in their
backpack and if they want to they can
print the modules out but they don't
have to so we have a price reduction we
have irritated publishers and we have
longer to actually have to develop a
weightlifting plan at the gym so but
which is fine you know if I can do
CrossFit you can to either yes sir
the the programmers are writing the
questions both for the physics and the
algebra course from Ryerson and in
Toronto and from this here ink and we
consult together but they do all the
coding they send me problems and I tell
them no that's not quite right or yeah
that's perfect okie dokie thank you
[Applause]